some people consume sugar substitutes
because they think it's a good way to
cut back on calories and stay healthy
but some studies suggest that these
artificial sweeteners may actually raise
your blood sugar levels and change the
types of bacteria in your intestines
changes like this could potentially lead
to obesity high blood sugar and lots of
other health problems decades ago
vintage ads build sugar as a diet aid a
quick source of energy with few calories
but not all energy sources are created
equal some might give you a quick boost
but will leave you craving calories in
no time
these inefficient energy sources can
also lead to weight gain and obesity
many processed foods have extremely high
levels of added sugar eating healthier
foods with protein fiber and good fats
will keep you satisfied longer in their
quest to depict sugar as a health food
vintage ads were quick to point out the
high level of sugar in fruit while it's
true that fruit contains a fair amount
of natural sugar
it also comes packaged with nutrients
fiber and a low energy density and that
makes it difficult to overeat on added
sugar the stuff you always find in
bottled fruit juices is what you really
need to watch out for these are just
empty calories similar to what you'd
find in soda
many so-called helped products are
sweetened with organic cane sugar what
the makers of these products don't tell
you is that this raw sugar delivers no
actual health benefits even when you
compare it to regular sugar the
processing method might be different but
the chemical makeup is the same if you
over consume it your body and metabolism
will suffer in the same ways with all
these sugar related problems you might
be tempted to cut sugar out of your diet
completely but not all foods labeled
sugar free are truly free of added sugar
many recipes that make this claim have
simply replaced sugar with agave nectar
honey or other substitutes that are just
sugar by another name since the body is
less efficient at breaking down these
high fructose alternatives sugar free
foods can actually be worse for you if
you can always choose unprocessed foods
that have as little added sugar as
possible